il y aura bien un deuxième ep air en
france après celui de flamanville le
prochain réacteur nucléaire de troisième
génération sera construit à penly en
seine maritime
le marché a été emporté par edf aux
dépens de gdf suez
de leur côté les militants écologistes
de l'association sortir du nucléaire se
disent très mécontents de cette décision
patrick esther en france les 58
réacteurs nucléaires d'edf produisent
80% de l'électricité pour renouveler les
centrales les plus anciennes
areva a conçu le p r un réacteur
présenté comme plus économique et plus
sûr
il est doté d'un double mur d'enceinte
en béton et en cas d'accident grave
comme par exemple la fonte du coeur
celui ci serait récupérée par des bacs
de céramique placé en dessous à
flamanville dans la manche et non sans
difficulté edf a déjà entrepris la
construction du premier repère français
hier nicolas sarkozy a annoncé dans un
communiqué sa décision de construire un
second exemplaire deux sites étaient
pressentis chooz dans les ardennes
plutôt soutenu par le groupe gdf suez et
ben lee en seine maritime
ce sera donc pas en lits dont la
réalisation était confiée une nouvelle
fois à edf
son concurrent gdf suez est invité à
participer minoritairement au projet
lors du grenelle de l'environnement
nicolas sarkozy avait affirmé qu'il n'y
aurait pas de nouveaux sites nucléaires
en france le p r de penly sera donc
édifié sur le terrain côtoyant les deux
réacteurs de 13 100 mégawatts
les gens service les élus locaux se
réjouissent bien sûr de cette décision
du togo noël parce que leur département
notre région touchée par les pôles de
chômage avions grand besoin de ceux de
ce coup de fouet
les opposants au nucléaire
dont le p r est la bête noire juge le
projet irresponsable
le premier repère avaient été construits
suscité un débat public qui précisait
bien qu'il s'agissait d'un prototype en
fait il s'agissait de voir après mise en
exploitation si la centrale était
quelque chose d'intéressant ou pas et en
fait là on se rend compte que le débat
public est totalement bafoués puisque
les conclusions du débat ne sont pas du
tout prise en compte
on construit un deuxième père avec le
premier n'est pas encore construit a
pris du retard
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment se
moquer du ed espère réaliser une dizaine
de pme d'ici à 2020 mais la construction
du troisième réacteur sera probablement
confiée à gdf suez à chaud chaud